I'll tell you right now Briana tell me
all about it it but you did
I'm reading a book set in Dublin right
now so it's really fascinating
information Briana listen guys I'm Ryan
right
I am Briana white and yeah on camera you
look exceptionally white right now hey
man I increase winter so I gotta tan in
a few months okay
okay Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
the weird trailer English version by
Aldo Jose Aldo Jones has fourteen
thousand nine hundred seventy-nine
subscribers this video currently has two
hundred seventy 1827 views my friend I
sound like I'm supporting you you're on
your way to becoming just as successful
as me and I could already tell by the
title that you do not put as much work
into your videos as I do
I'm Ryan Wright this is Brianna
I read you guys
but the [ __ ] like Roger Rabbit thank you
what the [ __ ] is happy bark Camp Daily
Planet
what's your position on the back these
being trampled on your city people
living your parents that's the fun when
things are above the laws will hit the
grip which considering every time your
hero stakes a cat on a tree you're ready
puff-piece territory
about an alien to the burn displacement
missile girl doesn't share your opinion
mr. Wayne
maybe Gotham City and me have a bad
history
freeze dressed like clowns
boys hmm how are we hi hello likes it is
a pleasure
neck side
you know the oldest lie in America
senator the power can be innocent
something about the war to us
you know you can't when it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
Son of Krypton versus back okay three
syllable word for any thought too big
for little minds
sunny bird what means to be a man you
began already man won't kill God here's
Johnny
it's got to be done
Wow
Wow I feel like good I feel like I feel
like a really a happy that video was
like a positive delight man that was
amazing
that's one of those videos you have to
watch eight billion times oh do see like
each frame this is something this is one
of those videos that you're gonna share
on your social networks never seen this
video guys I just share with them yeah
Oh funny weirdly like impressive too
because it starts off like this is
[ __ ] really weird and then it's this
is really funny and then halfway through
you're like the style kind of works
reversal yeah cuz yeah cuz he's so
committed to it it's not every once in a
while it's like in almost every frame
exactly yeah you kind of like adjust to
it and it looks starts looking kind of
cool and normal yeah it starts looking
inventive in not just silly not it was
such a random amalgamation of things
there's so much in there like anything
any weird cartoon any in the faces
though the face how did he think it wink
you made a wink that looks so realistic
yeah I like when he has that the little
tidbits I liked when he had the
newspaper
yeah like the wink and then I liked that
picture they had a Ben Affleck as George
Reeves is Superman posing in the back
jesse eisenberg doing the karate chop
God when he did this Sabbath yeah I died
that's so [ __ ] fine but awesome I know
I said I'm gonna try to cut back on this
but seriously there could have been some
penis jokes in there why weren't there
why weren't there aldo jones your last
name is Jones maybe there are they're
just hidden in different
frame so he doesn't explicitly get in
trouble no videos like this you get a
girl laughing imagine you were here next
to this right now
Aldo Jones more like Aldo
found it you always do how do you just
cast that hooked into the water
eventually reel in that joke put it back
in the ocean
I don't leave it's a little it was cool
because we watched the we watched this
specific trailer before watching this
video and you know seeing the serious
tone and everything I this this was like
great edition of I love how committed he
was to the mannequin estat he was
creating yes behind all this it was only
it's like it seemed like he looked at
every frame and imagine what could go
here what could we do it here
it wasn't like just throwing some random
insert if he really let his imagination
take over the editing oh 100% and then
did a really technical job good job of
it
totally totally those words were in the
wrong order but you know what I mean you
know he did a very good job yeah
technically I give him a good hand job
listen guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today to the real
rejects Breanna White has a gaming
channel sibling rivalry it's awesome
it's an awesome channel just tell you
that right now
featuring her good-looking brother to
check it out just as equally hot as her
what's up man how you doing what's his
name you Adam Adam the first man
first man it's my brother so maybe I'll
just stop you there
Matthew tomini
there's a normal school douchebag that
the first thing he said to me was I
wonder if anyone got hot and I like this
girl who when I was chubby she rejected
me twice I know what it's like to be a
reject and now I'm skinny I'm too shy to
ask her out and six he dated her and
broke up with her the same week and an
eighth what should great what should I
do
what he's in eighth grade and then who's
this girl who art is she rejecting don't
she NE had a boyfriend what he should do
about this girl that he likes cuz his
why is he not just dated her in sixth
grade I see talking third person point
of view it's clearly about him no he's
asking what should I do
Matthew here's what I advise for you my
friend you got to read the book how to
wooden friends and influence people 21
irrefutable laws of leadership and who
moved my cheese something like that well
it's a great metaphor it's actually a
good beginner book to start off with I'd
also recommend Jim Ron's a challenge to
succeed where you learn the five
principles of life success and personal
development and then you'll realize this
girl is worth nothing because she
doesn't do anything along those lines
she doesn't work on herself she doesn't
motivate herself she's probably gonna
get like incredibly of not like Oh
fattens like a little over way where you
can forgive it I'm talking about like we
don't know really Valerie's well you
know what she made him a reject I know
what it's like just because she didn't
want to go out with him doesn't mean
there's something wrong with her maybe
they're just not each other's types and
that's okay too
all right when we were 17 you didn't
want to go out with me because you got a
problem cuz I had a problem yeah it was
my fault
it was your fault this is a problem you
didn't respond to my myspace post okay
it was a joke pretty nice face that's
how old we are
yeah
if you read the whole post I was asking
you out at the end of the PUD let's not
joke about traumatic incidents people
take care